>> Let's say you're a college freshman and you're choosing a major. You're
debating between Nursing and Geography. So, you decide that you're going to look
at how much Nursing majors make as opposed to Geography majors. Fortunately,
these days, data is often easily accessible. You find that the frequency
distributions of Nursing majors' salaries and Geography majors' salaries looks
like this. So, let's say that these histograms were created from the data from
everyone who either majored in Nursing or Geography, and the x-axis represents
their annual income in thousands. From these distributions, approximately what
income do most Nursing majors make, and approximately what income do most
Geography majors make?